we're here society foundation actor
center yes and we're in this conference
room here and it's an amazing resource
and yeah absolutely um I was test heart
lead into SAG in 2004 that was actually
third Robot Chicken so that was just
like mind-blowing and I joined sag first
chance I got the spring of 2005 and one
of the first things I wanted to know was
will what is that about you know you
hear a lot of actors that don't really
know what sight does other than the fact
that yes they help you with contracts
and I hope you get better pay and
they're better projects but a lot of
times you hear people whining about the
dues or things like that initiation feel
like well what else do we get and the
truth is is that there's a lot I mean
sag itself has a ton of programs that
you can reach out to and look for but
where we're at right now is the SAG
Foundation which is a non-profit so none
of your sag dues goes to this charity
it's a non-profit foundation and you
donated so all the money is from private
donors or you know you can check when
you get your dues you can check to have
a portion go here and I saw an
opportunity bonds here so I first
started off they have a program called
book paddles and you can volunteer and
be a reader that goes around and reads
the kids at schools there's a you come
for one orientation you know to be a
book pal and I'm not sure who's running
the program right now it's changed hands
over a few years but they'll coordinate
what schools are in need and so my first
couple years I'm sag I was doing all of
their special events I was one of the
hosts in the rotation that they were
sending in special events and I hosted a
program at the Grove just called book
pals at the Grove and it was a monthly
thing outside on the lawn with the
waterfall and first time I web I thought
I was gonna be sitting there readings
like five kids on the lawn and I get
there and there's a PA system and
there's like the kids were their parents
and it was it was a big production and
we had like special celebrities come
down from time to time and I've just
gotten so many opportunities presented
to myself from giving to organizations
like sac County
so there's bookpals which is something
you mom's here but then as far as things
they provides actors there's the
conversation series there's a casting
access program and there's life raft
each three are different tailored events
celebrities speaking workshops premieres
and screenings they're all free usually
you can bring a guest sometimes their
service striction and you can't but you
do have to be a member of sag to do it
now with the merger of Sega after I'm
not sure how the SAG Foundation is
operating because that's a little bit
separate so I'd have to clarify that but
I'm assuming it's you know what
everybody's sag after now so all members
and then where we are right now is the
Resource Center which was just created
about a year and a half ago and was all
done through donations and they opened
up about a year and a half it might be
two years now and obviously we're in a
conference room that had any actor can
reserve for anything whether they have
to do a taping whether they're doing an
interview rehearsal script reading on
for free and there's also six computers
available for free free wireless if you
bring your laptop printer there's also
now that Don LaFontaine voice overlap or
you can actually go in and like work on
your voiceovers demo record auditions
and it's all free for union members you
just have to call and reserve check-in
it's it's amazing and then within the
foundation there's more opportunities to
volunteer at all of those events that I
just mentioned so a lot of times I would
be the girl during the check-in at those
events you know and you know next thing
you know those Mel Gibson those in the
wrestler right now not Mel Gibson it was
the price leg guy Mickey Rourke Mel
Gibson when I come with Mel goes over to
her next thing you know you're welcome
Mickey work like up to the stage you
know and you're like hey nice job you
know and I've just found the people here
at the site foundation to be just so
grateful for the help they have pizza
parties all the time and volunteer
appreciation days and you get invited
for special events and so if you're a
member of the Union you should
definitely check out
the things that there are for you to
give back and then you know in turn you
always receive more than you give at
least that's that's the plan that's what
we hope what you thinking with samples
of sometimes you volunteered and how it
turned into something um well back to
the hosting this stuff I have
volunteered to do the book pals hosting
and I don't know how maybe is a year
down the line apparently the city of Los
Angeles called thanked Foundation and
they wanted an a-list actress to host an
event somehow they got my name and I
co-hosted the Los Angeles emergency
preparedness fair with the fire chief of
Los Angeles they held it over in this
park over here target was a sponsor you
know I got a lot of kinds of guests gift
cards and stuff and it was just it was
an amazing day
you know co-hosting with the chief of
the fire chief yeah yeah and then
there's also good you know like red
carpet for years and things like that I
got to go to the running with scissors
red carpet premiere or I got to go up
and introduce myself to Annette Bening
amour and baby and tell them like
whatever amazing I'm sometimes I am just
so ballsy sometimes and other times I'm
not but I literally have I spotted them
I had my business card in my hand and I
just went out to them and you know said
you did a wonderful job introduced
myself
they were receptive and I said can I
give you my business card maybe we'll
work together someday and it might have
ended up in a trashcan who knows but
yeah but that came there being a
volunteer at psych foundation it was a
gift to go to the premiere
you